- As always, we are gonna end
with something super uplifting
from social media.
This is #What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
All right, I've seen little girls obsessed
with dressing as princesses, superheros,
even Ruth Bader Ginsburg, a
superhero in her own rite.
But one five-year-old has a fascination
I've never heard from a kid,
and it's perfect to feature as part
of Women's History Month.
Here is her momma explaining.
(air whooshing)
- My five-year-old was Eleanor Roosevelt
for the Presidents' Day thing at school.
And ever since she put on that costume,
she has not taken it off.
She wants an Eleanor
Roosevelt birthday party.
She's asked for a
stuffed Eleanor Roosevelt
to sleep with at night.
She has asked that I refer
to her as your ladyship
from now on.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Oh my god.
A couple months later,
Essie's interest in Eleanor Roosevelt
is as strong as ever, y'all.
We have her and her momma,
Liz, on the line. (laughing)
(audience cheering)
What's up, Essie?
What's up, Liz?
Oh my gosh, I love you, Essie.
- Hey, Kelly.
- Oh, Essie, you look great.
So Liz, this all started, like you said,
with a Presidents' Day project.
So how quickly did you
realize Essie was Eleanor fan
for life, like she was deep?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, so, I put her and
her sister to bed one night
and went down to the kitchen
and poured myself a glass of wine.
And then I turned around
and there she was standing
in the dark
with her Eleanor Roosevelt costume on
(Kelly laughing)
over her pajamas.
And honestly, it was a
jump scare at that point.
(audience laughing)
But then, after that, she said,
"Mommy can we go to Target
and get an Eleanor Roosevelt doll
because I wanna sleep with her tonight?"
And I said, "Well, they don't
make those kinds of dolls
at Target."
(Kelly laughing)
But the internet came through
because I posted on TikTok
that I was looking for
Eleanor Roosevelt merch
(audience and Kelly laughing)
and people from all around the country
have sent us the most amazing things.
We got a handwritten letter
from Eleanor Roosevelt,
and we got a "Life" magazine
with her portrait on the cover.
And it's just been so amazing.
- Aw, that is so awesome.
(audience applauding)
Gosh, she's so cute.
So, Essie, do you love your Eleanor doll?
- Yeah, yes, yes,
and yes.
(audience laughing)
- I love it. (laughing)
- Yes.
- Yes, that's an affirmative
answer, I like it.
So, Liz, what does it mean to you
that Essie's just so
into Eleanor Roosevelt?
I think that's so cool.
Like what a cool like
superhero figure for a kid.
- I know, I love it.
I've done a lot of
reflection on it actually,
and it's just like,
it's so important for children to learn
about all these amazing
historical figures.
And it's really inspired
me to research on my own
and find out more about women's history
and Eleanor Roosevelt.
And I've learned that she was
one of the First Ladies
that had news conferences,
and she really revolutionized
the entire job of First Lady.
She changed it from hostess
and president's wife
to a woman who would
step in for her husband
when he was sick.
And,
- Yeah.
- I'm just, I hope that Essie knows that
- It's possible.
- These are the kinda barriers
that she can break and that
she can change the world.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
Oh my gosh, Essie, you are so cute.
Aw, I love it.
Well, thank you so much, Liz, for sharing,
and Essie, I'm so, you look so adorable
and I love your doll.
Thank you y'all for being on the show.
I'm liking your post right now.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Speaker] It's so cute.
- All right, that's not all, though.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate
fearless, inspiring kiddos
just like Essie.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Oh my gosh.
That's amazing.
- $1,000?
- Oh, thank you.
(Kelly laughing)
- Thank you, ladies.
(crowd applauding continues)
Have a blessed day.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Chrissy Teigen, Matt Iseman, Lucas Gage,
Jenny, Jemmy, and Easton Corbin.
Have a great day, y'all, and if it's not,
try and change it.